excellent um i'd love to chat quickly
about a company called palabra which is
actually a launch company now
palabra is let's talk about the business
first and then we can touch base about
the person
um the website is palabra.io
um actually originally got started
as a product a bit adjacent to it now
um originally started as kind of a
zapier
for email and and and karen the founder
did a nice job of focusing it on a a
much more specific use case which is
basically this
um no one has truly kind of dethroned
salesforce uh to date and i think the
right strategy to kind of
to dethroning it is not trying to build
the whole thing whole hog but just
plucking piece by piece off and so the
message for palabra is this and maybe
we'll pitch it to cortland here
you have users arriving on your website
there are different flows
in a funnel in terms of where you'd like
them to be you're not a traditional sas
business you're not selling software but
maybe you can imagine person made an
account
person submitted uh one upvote person
wrote a post
person wrote five comments and maybe
that's kind of your terminal goal is i
want to get a lot of users into the five
comment phase because you figured out
boy if they just write five comments
they're committed um
and so it organizes your users in
different steps of your funnels and
it'll basically automatically manage
when to email each user based on
triggers and different steps of their
funnels
and it's not the only tool in the world
that does this but i do think it's one
of the more specific and precise ones
like
you can contort salesforce to do this
but um
you know you can control a database to
do whatever you want um
it's still helpful to have a more
specific tool karen i
you know i i really see as i don't know
if you guys have read um
his books as elizabeth salander from um
uh the girl with the dragon tattoo
you're kind of penultimate uh
hacker um uh female hacker personality
who is seen seemingly very
strong uh and quiet like you won't hear
her
much on you do the all sorts of calls
quiet assassin
you said it best so um well i mean it's
so interesting because i watched her
we're having like a little inception
point here i watched her on
you having her display the product and i
just watched her and i just thought
who is this person and i think she had
like five hundred dollars in revenue or
something completely de minimis
and i just said to my team like usually
we're looking for more than this like
five to 25k is kind of our sweet spot
i was like get me this person we have to
get just so
completely understood our customer and
then i was watching her build the
product and i had looked at different
videos you had done with her
um and i think that's actually something
very strong you're doing daniel and
you're
even though you're an introvert you're
fake being an extrovert pretty well on
your live streams
nobody would know and those live streams
are so
so powerful that you do where you bring
somebody in
who's a founder who's notable who's got
knowledge and then you just have them
give feedback to another founder
and then you know people are lurking and
so i'm saying they're lurking and i'm
like
wow what a great idea she's doing this
email automation and
these triggers and it feels it looks
like notion it looks beautiful so it's
got this incredible design and then
i went under the hood and i started
looking at you know her expense base and
how quickly the product velocity was and
that's one thing i'll say daniel about
the companies remote arrow and palabra
the product velocity is
extraordinary on those two companies
some of the fastest i've seen and
we all know speed is important because
with the iterations comes the lessons
right
you start to learn and understand your
customers faster than your competitors
or just another company
and that means you can get to
profitability get to break even
you know before you run out of capital
or run out of energy cortland any
thoughts on palabra
yeah i like that at insight that they're
uh moving quickly i was talking to
david shu the founder of retool on the
andy hackers podcast a while back
and when retool got started i was always
in their little intercom chat bubble
saying like hey i need this feature i
need this
and they're incredibly quick about
executing and getting new features out
the door
uh same with heroku in the early days i
was using heroku and i was talking to
the founders and the early engineers and
they were like iterating super quick uh
and every company where i've seen this
pattern where i'm trying to build
something and they're like building
features you know
the same day i request it uh i regret
not
investing in those companies because
they always end up being worth a ton
so maybe we should be investing in
palabra uh well it's interesting you
know
that is a that's a very interesting
insight is that the velocity could equal
the success eventually it could be like
a really good
tell keep going cortland you want more
iterations through the loop and the
faster you're going the more iterations
you go to the loop and the faster you
learn and your course correct
uh i also like that it seems very
opinionated
um these kind of tools are andy hackers
eat these tools up
because they're all trying to build
websites it takes a long time to build
something
it's hard to find traction and when an
opinionated tool comes around that gives
you more insight about your users
and not only that but tells you like
this is how it should be like you should
have
a funnel set up that you know your
customers or users go through et cetera
people just build better companies not
because they're genius founders they've
read a bunch of strategy playbooks but
because the tools themselves
are telling them what they should focus
on so i like this because i think it
will end up
you know if something gets big
increasing the size of the top of the
funnel
because more founders are going to find
it easier to get started and to find
success
which means i'll have more success
stories to broadcast on any hackers
itself
i am in love with a new product it's
called chart hop it's new to me i mean
it's been around to be honest
many of you are already using it you can
go see it at charthop.comtwist
when you want to create an
organizational chart for your company
this is a critical moment that shows you
are venture fundable if you know
these are my top executives these are my
units this is my group that's going to
do customer support this is my marketing
group
this is my cto this is uh finance this
is operations
well you can do all that and make like
some cruddy little
drawing with like some painting program
or sketching program or
you can make your own org chart that has
all the data
around all of your people we call this
people data we call it human capital in
the industry
but in this org chart you can also put
in performance reviews
right into the org chart and you
centralize all the data there
and you can build a nice agile adaptable
and inclusive team because you can look
and say hey
where's my diversity how am i doing with
building out my organization and
at the core a startup is about people we
all know that
go to charthop.com twist and try it out
today you're gonna get 600
credits i talked to the founders i
talked to the marketing team over there
and i said just give people hundreds of
dollars
just come over the top and throw like
just grab a handful of hundies and throw
them
at the audience well here it is
charthop.com twist 600
credits go and get it set up now
basically that 600 is going to cover
your first five employees on the
platform
which makes it no brainer to get started
go ahead and check out chart
hop c-h-a-r-t h-o-p dot com slash twist
for six hundy get it now because i don't
know if they're gonna keep that offer up